and this morning China accused President
Trump of damaging the global trade
system the president officially
announced a 25 percent tariff on
imported steel and a 10 percent tariff
on imported aluminum yesterday Jericka
Duncan is at the White House with how
the move does not go as far as it could
have Jericka good morning good morning
mr. Trump said that those tariffs are
flexible they could go up and down in
that certain countries could be exempted
the White House says that these tariffs
could roll out in just two weeks
we just want fairness president Trump
decided to slap tariffs on steel and
aluminum imports arguing he had no
choice they're a matter of necessity for
our security the President signed the
order surrounded by steel and aluminum
workers our industries have been
targeted for years and years decades in
fact by unfair foreign trade practices
leading to the shuttered plants and
mills the laying off of millions of
workers the tariffs will hit US allies
like Britain Germany South Korea Japan
and Australia Canada and Mexico will be
exempted while nafta negotiations
continue China the focus of the
president's ire on trade will largely be
spared as it accounts for only a small
percentage of u.s. steel imports Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer said
letting China off the hook while
penalizing US allies was a mistake it's
so typical of this White House even when
they have a good idea they mess it up
because they don't think it through top
Republicans Lobby the president to
change course tariffs have the potential
to significantly undermine US jobs I'm
just not a fan of broad-based
across-the-board tariffs because I think
you'll have a lot of unintended
consequences European Central Bank
President Mario Draghi called the
president's decision dangerous this is
Gary Kahn's last meeting in the cabinet
the president's economic adviser Gary
Cohn resigned after failing to convince
mr. Trump that tariffs were a bad idea
he may be a globalist but I still like
him
the president also joked that Kohn could
return to the White House after he quote
made another couple hundred million
dollars in the private sector but
according to the president Kohn would
not come back as an economic adviser
because as president Trump noted he said
he just wasn't as strong as he wanted
him to be on tariffs John
well thanks Jericka don't let the door
hit you in the back on your way out
that's starting anything to say